bienvenue sur notre site de montbéliard
on va avoir le temps de faire
connaissance en commencez déjà par cet
après midi et justement fatin et aude ne
se connaissaient pas encore ce matin ils
viennent de la région parisienne et de
l'oise elles partagent le même goût pour
l'ingénierie et rêvé de venir à l'utbm
moi j'aimerais travailler dans un bureau
d'étude
dans tout ce qui touche à l'automobile
ou l'aéronautique
et je sais que c'est ici que je pourrais
y arriver c'est des seules écoles qui va
regrouper ingénierie mécanique et design
c'est un mois c'est la seule école
d'ingénieurs que j'ai trouvé qu'il irait
sont rassemblés les deux et qui du coup
on peut rassembler le côté artistique et
le côté science 8 que j'avais ces
étudiants de font le pari que
l'automobile ou l'aéronautique ont
encore un avenir en france elle arrive
dans le nord franche comté alors que
leur école vient d'obtenir un
financement de 10 millions d'euros sur
cinq ans pour développer le mobi campus
27 partenaires des industriels des
enseignants des institutionnels vont
travailler d'une manière encore inédite
pour revoir de manière collaborative les
formations pour l'automobile du ceap et
au doctorat la filière fait face à des
mutations très importante on les connaît
la transition écologique mais aussi
l'industrie 4.0 tout ce qui est digital
isation et qu'on a beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur ce que vont devenir
les métiers à cinq ou dix ans mais on le
prend comme ça les besoins de
compétences va pas disparaître il va
simplement se transformer ce qu'on dit
c'est que c'est uniquement
collectivement par l'adaptation donc
ensemble qu'on peut réussir au mieux à
capter ces tendances et à s'y adapter et
à la base il y à la recherche grâce à ce
simulateur les équipes de l'utbm travail
sur la perception de l'autonomie des
véhicules se sont ralentis parce que le
docteur passage piéton et qui sait les
étudiants qui viennent tout juste
d'intégrer cette école travailleront
peut-être un jour sur les recherches
autour de l'ergonomie de cette voiture
autonome
[Musique]